hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley all right hit it fatty hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find out
they go
to be classy or they're just a big old
piece of trash
oh yeah i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful spring day we're
down here in aunt toddy's basement
she continues to let our success go to
her head sure went to the local pizzeria
yesterday to get a slice
whose picture is up on the whole they
got today's [ __ ] cody right next to
travolta i'm like lady pump the brakes a
little bit
yeah my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me
he is an international businessman he
books the flights the hotels
this guy's got the keys because i have a
credit card that's the only reason he
could leave me in albuquerque if he
wanted to and he might
kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
what's up thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and you as you know those
numbers are
true to [ __ ] room cooking and then
patreon's really [ __ ] cooking
i mean youtube i mean i'm about to
cancel a youtube subscription just focus
all on patreon baby
uh check it out you get bonus episodes
of ayg you get episodes of hard feelings
and then every month we'll do a live
stream with the top tier members you ask
us questions we ask you questions it's a
good
[ __ ] time we love it having a nice
quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire he's the
man that makes us look good he's a magic
man but you know him as t-bone but his
mama named him
thomas something something yeah so we
just call him toby
what's up dudes i thought it was tobias
it's not sure if it's about
thomas tom i gotta book his flights i'm
like what's your name again
dude this kid's screwball and i've
explained it to foley like 40 times and
every time he goes
damn what's your full name thomas
benjamin wilkinson
mcmullen
wilkinson i'm the only person with a dog
name that's an improvement
for like toby they're like that's better
for sure yeah mom was a big bullets fan
back in the day
but gang that's neither here nor there
because this is a family episode
we have some company some special
company here with us today
again little star power in the building
we love them you know
them we're gonna do some questions with
you he gets to ask
answer your question it's gonna be
fantastic he's the host of the skeptic
tank give it up for the one the only
mr ari shafir thank you i am the one and
only oh no there is another ari shaffer
it has to be another yeah me and martyr
i was writing down my name on a [ __ ]
on a tour and i was like oh somebody
heard my name and i crossed it off and
then
i heard somebody go like hey who crossed
my [ __ ] name who crossed off my name
already
an orthodox jewish ari shafir that i met
in myanmar but there's got to be a bunch
of them i would
know as far as comedy goes you are the
one and the only and even if there was
20 guys with your name
you are a one there are certain people
that i say the one and the only
you know to be nice or to give a little
john smith yeah yeah
but you're you're you're a very unique
individual thanks i appreciate it you're
back from a six-month tour of south
america
yeah central america open it up scoping
it out for the invasion
yeah i could you know what i was
thinking on the way in you
you got a pretty good body yeah you know
you could be mossad
dude coming from you that's that's
really means absolutely you got a body
this table has a good body you're coming
for me but you could be massaged
i could be you could be not he's too
high all the time do you know chuck
mcgall or whatever it's called what's
the brav
chuck mcgraw is the guy who went to high
school i could never get that right why
is it somebody's name what's it called
krav maga oh my god it's my favorite
kind of uh martial arts because it's
just non-stop it's like hit hit hit
throw a hamburger at you [ __ ]
um do you know that no i don't know
you're a jiu jitsu guy though
expert i am are you really tenth planet
trained a white belt
under the honorable edward bravo quit
showing off
over 17 taps no it's been a while yeah
once i got my third staph infection and
[ __ ] second ring
i don't know from the [ __ ] dirty mats
those [ __ ] brazil
i think you're doing it wrong yeah
probably it's just a scrape
guy gets gonorrhea from karate dude i
was i was playing
i got hurt somebody got eye herpes once
it i think uh
henderson whatever high herpes who's
henderson
you just named some guy in your karate
club yeah he wasn't with us but i got
dude i was limping and joe rucker was
playing pool and he was like why are you
lumpy i was like i got that [ __ ]
spider bite or something it's [ __ ]
killing me it's like spider bites makes
still makes you limp
yeah he's like show it to me and he's
like dude you have a bad staff in fact
where was it where where did it enter in
your toe
no my knee oh yeah those are bad you
could you lose your leg on that yeah he
was like how long have you had him like
that's like a month he's like dude you
go to the hospital i'm like
i'll go studios no no i'm going to drive
you to the hospital that's like really
bad
it looks like it's systemic but i'm fine
skating it
what the hell's i herpes i don't know i
didn't see him
i don't know he was [ __ ] skull
[ __ ] somebody the wrong way yeah
let's get this straight for everybody
out there all right now i get cold sores
too
you got herpes herpes is herpes it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter where
it is
stop trying to sugarcoat it with it's a
fever blister whatever it is
you got a [ __ ]
on your lip or whatever i knew somebody
that used to get it on her
uh on her finger that's where she sounds
like a nice guy
that's where she would get her sores
when she flared up so all she had to do
is not finger somebody
yeah square banded she had it for a
weird reason they took a piece of
something off of her lip and put it on
her finger
what a piece of meat or something some
kind of no so she had some kind of
surgery or accident where they took
something from her lip or inside of her
mouth
and put it on her finger and she had it
this sounds like a goosebump story
get the [ __ ] out of here that's not a
real story yeah
i took something from her mouth and it
just so happened to be the part with
herpes
it was my boss her name was rocky she
sold lasers
got a herpes transplant wait your boss
rocky female had
herpes on her finger and she sold lasers
you sold laser hair removal
oh really did a lot of business on long
island i bet oh yeah yeah those skinny
[ __ ]
a bunch of hairy broads out there in
massapequa so she had oral herpes
and then and then science took over and
then science takes over
yeah yeah yeah i'm still not buying that
yeah i mean you lie about a lot of stuff
that i i'll give you
i'm not lying about it herpes rocky and
gino
we can't get rid of it but we can move
it yeah yeah his face was on the
on the wall of the palm they went to the
palm so much in one year that they got
their faces put on there
in vegas no here uh oh the palm
restaurant that'd be real trashy
oh the palm restaurant i thought you
meant vegas too no
never been no you got a little
excitement coming up you got a bat
mitzvah
yeah i do tonight so the reason i wanted
to save it for the pot and i wanted to
ask you
yeah go for it what are you dropping oh
uh what are you
yeah yep okay so one thing you should
know is i was poor for a long time
so i set the tone but you're not now you
got cash you got cash but i set the tone
early
for being the cool uncle who doesn't do
that kind of stuff
that's what i did too hold on we're just
changing that how many other nieces and
nephews have been bar mitzvahed or about
midfield yet
five-ish really yeah yeah and they're
nothing to shake a stick at you guys you
got to come correct
yeah that's like a wedding for you cat
licks out there yeah yeah you can
sometimes it's thousands the first time
i realized i was like oh i got to change
this
i was at one of their houses on hanukkah
which is their jewish
christmas
oh yeah lights off here we go yeah and
all the kids just stared at me like
it's almost like dude i get it if you
want to sense that you're here every
year and you didn't bring anything i
didn't even think i didn't consider it
and that's wait
wait hold on you showed up to hanukkah
empty-handed i even considered
secretary's like
i'll commit you guys and it just was
this your sister yeah
sister and her kids and the other sister
yeah he's [ __ ] screwballs dude yeah
this guy he's how did you he's playing
another game
do you not know what hanukkah is i just
went i just forgot about it
i was living on mac and cheese for years
i couldn't afford anything i get it now
i get it
you're talking to a guy already gets it
so what are you dropping today
so now i like to give it a specialist my
first one
i gave him a drone which was like nice
yeah
instead of a couple hundred bucks like
come on so uh then one of my brought to
a a jets game
um one i brought but i got those like
agent seats where you're like up front
where you can bang on the wall
okay i brought one to a a caps rangers
game
okay so that's really cool just in front
of destefano like real good
now how do you how do you how do you
tell them that i just said i'm going to
take you to a ranger game and then you
pass by the front entrance it goes no
it's it's here i'm like ah
we're going to a different place and
then you go in and you start going down
and you're like where are we you're
behind where they see all the [ __ ]
the knicks like the marquis
and he's like what what is this yeah
yeah damn
taking him down and he was like one of
his friends were there
take a picture of me from [ __ ] the
[ __ ] wait you think boys too
no his boys was there i think he just
happened to be there it was great
up in the [ __ ] nosebleeds like me and
uncle are you down on the floor baby
it was great it was great but i dropped
nothing on that yeah you're getting free
you're getting absolutely yes
absolutely what it doesn't what he
doesn't know won't hurt him but hold on
i'll give you that
no you don't do the move where you give
them a card with hey i'm taking you a
rangers game in it
so the next one yes i said i'm gonna
take you he's a big basketball fan i
said i'm gonna take you
to a basketball game however um
i'm i i'm now persona non grata at nba
games
so oh yeah you you take your nephew you
two get the [ __ ] kicked out of you i
gotta i gotta test it out first i gotta
go to the next game on my own to see
what happens
hey kid you into formula one at all yeah
you ever been to the staples center
let's go
my name's still good over there i mean
luckily the knicks hates the lakers so
it's like i got a chance but
i don't know yeah i gotta test it out
myself first you can say that
yeah otherwise we're going to a college
basketball game i i might have to get
flipped off yeah
you can't go just no basketball game
yeah i think the basketball community is
done with me
i wouldn't even walk by the fourth
street
i've been with you when people like
outside the cellar and people been like
hey ari and you're like oh [ __ ] i don't
know how this is going to go
anybody who's a huge man you're like
okay thank you that's when you use your
raspberries
yeah i am getting a new crop of people
running after me like
like younger black like 1920 who didn't
really grow up with coyote
so don't really give a [ __ ] and they're
just like kobe bryant
i love it young kids they don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah they play by their own rules uh i
saw what that that same
night outside the cellar some guy just
gave you like a huge bag of weed
remember
he was like yeah can you take a picture
and just say you love like mister yeah
yeah i'll do that and he just gave you
like a pillowcase i had to walk away
from my friends he was like why are you
walking away like they're kind of
squares
let's just go over here i'll do this
i'll give you an ounce for a shout out
i'm like i don't know what a shout out
means but you had me announced
mary so he got he's got a [ __ ] bag of
[ __ ] are you into the jets at all huh
yeah
yeah so this one i'm taking on a camping
trip white water rafting
that's pretty cool hold on that's
expensive you're staying overnight and
stuff like that
did you win this on a game show or
something like that did you
i'll just i got a tent well it will take
her to it's not outward bound or
something like that i'll leave her there
i'm like figure it out
scared straight so that's how many days
is that it should be overnight
overnight i'll pick her up we'll go camp
set up camp where is it gonna be
i don't know there's so many woods up
here i don't know somewhere up here
yeah i don't know too many white water
rafting spots in new york
yeah i'm not going to promise with a
white rotor after yeah i don't know well
that's what enticed me the white one or
otherwise you're just sleeping i don't
know what up
if we find a rainy season what are you
going to do but you know just like a
campfire
it's more that's a good time just you
and her yeah now are they more
conservative
like a [ __ ] like do they not do super
cool [ __ ] all the time
they're more they're less conservative
than their other orthodox jewish friends
like they will go on like trips and then
people ask me like
can orthodox shoes not go like to like
africa on like safari like no they can't
they just don't they just hoard their
money like china
yeah yeah why spend it yeah um but no so
there but
still it's like come on don't curse
around my kids really you should always
first more yeah anytime you give aria
roll he just
blatantly oh i was playing backhand with
one of them and i was like [ __ ] when he
hit like a double sixes and then and i
was like
emo dad are cursed or whatever and i'm
like don't [ __ ]
rat on me you [ __ ] idiot also what
kids are playing backgammon what are you
guys
what the [ __ ] shish
what's that that's the way you call it
the middle east josh bush
that's fantastic i played a guy for cab
fare once it was double or nothing he
was like
where where where down in the village
outside tel aviv and he was like we went
we were talking about cheshire and he
was like two players like yeah
i'm good and he goes tell you what let's
play for your cab fare and it was like
my buddy was like
can you win i'm like i mean it's by the
it's like 90
luck but yeah i can but he definitely
plays so we'll see
so it was like if we lose we don't have
enough money for a hostel that night
we're gonna sleep on the beach
jesus and if we win we take a pack of
that cap or get some beer did you win
[ __ ] yeah yeah i like that betting it
all on black yeah more of a checkers man
myself
yeah burger place so no envelope no cash
no cash but we're talking about a
star-studded event i would assume what
do you
what would you say your sister's
dropping on this uh on this one way too
much is that why they're great
no i don't think so 60 probably probably
40 to 60. jesus so it's not those
madison square garden ones do you ever
see those
what yeah it's something you read msg
and then you have to then some and then
if you get if you get where the [ __ ]
nets play you're like what the
[ __ ] is this mom and dad yeah that was
like super sweet 16 got big when i was
in like junior high and it was like
you know [ __ ] jermaine dupri or
whoever would come and sing it
yeah and then you get like a lamborghini
like i wanted the [ __ ] yellow one
yeah exactly they're mad they're never
going to be fine with anything
that's rich trash oh yeah yeah yeah my
community was at a vfw i got like 200
bucks never saw a [ __ ] diamond that
was that was big
that was that was i got i got i got like
900 bucks
and she gave me like 50 bucks of it and
we went to like valiant city or clover
my mom needed the money she was like
well we're hemmed up i just found my
bonds i had like 15 grand
we were just talking about these and i
was like are these good like yeah they
matured like
15 years ago 20 years ago so did you
cash them in
[ __ ] yes how much was it 15. it was a
lot yeah and then they go up a little
more
above jews do it right for the future
man i literally got one for 25 bucks
and i was like i waited like [ __ ] 19
years to catch it try to buy cigarettes
with it dude i cashed it in when i went
to college i'm like well this will get
me
took me that make me like a weekend we
had those two i never saw them i bought
one for my nephew when he was a baby
but it seemed like a scam i'm gonna put
it seemed like a real cheapo way of like
not giving them 50 bucks
it's like i'm gonna invest in america
and say it's still going to be around
and like
it was a good investment 25 years ago
now it's like i don't know yeah get into
bitcoin or something
shout out to chain link that's what i'm
in i don't like that i don't like that
commie talk down here
i'll tell you that right now usa yeah
all right gang this is a family episode
some questions we're going to be
answering your questions ari thank you
so much for sitting with us
and hey just show everybody i'm pretty
sure he just picked his finger now and
threw it in the corner like nothing
happened
to the trash can but i didn't there's
definitely a fingernail yeah and there's
a lid on the trash can what do you think
it was gonna land
on the lid press the button open it up
close itself as it was like saw it fly
like that was why would i do that
i respect the move i like to take them
and i like to curl them up into like
little uh
what do they call little falls no little
willies like beetle oh roly-polies yeah
little roly-polies
man we got a couple of kennedys sitting
down here jesus
christ i'm i like to pick my nails and
make rolly podies
i was kind of hoping nobody saw it but
then yeah she did it in front of three
cameras yeah
i mean you act like you act like you're
at a music festival there's five of us
looking at you
dude i was doing yoga online and
somebody pointed out like sometimes i
get like bad hemorrhoids and i get all
bloody so i go wad up toilet paper
and put it in there and then somebody
was like like right at
the minute mark like 1927 ari's bloody
hemorrhoid thing falls out
oh my god you get him that bad
he's not a bad [ __ ] he's got like a
starfish really
oh yeah how come you don't go get him
taken off a special lady
you can't get him taken out no i tried
they put the rubber bands in them and
kill them off and that
didn't work full surgery where the [ __ ]
are you getting this done
a field hospital in syria yeah [ __ ]
dumper
here bite this piece of wood i'm going
to rubber band your rulings let's go
to those little balls you put rubber
bands around them and cut off the
circulation so they eventually like
shrivel up die and then you know you
were boredom i guess or whatever
why don't you just get them to get them
lanced
mount sinai or something classy for
godzilla i went to a doctor you gotta
have a proctologist in the future no you
guys probably don't do but i went to a
doctor i went to a product no we don't
do butts yeah
no proctology you guys keep it above
board yeah everything from the from the
waistline we don't even do gyno stuff
what do you have in the family dentist
nice
ortho surgeon what are we talking about
just a regular dentist
i think i don't really know i think both
i think he's like really high-end
huh but then yeah i like it i like it
yeah have him do it no they're all
businessmen from there on out
nice yeah a couple of landlords i'm sure
i mean a couple of property owners
yeah i'm the black ship i got nothing
you're doing all right
i'm doing all right you got to be making
what they make there was an episode a
long time ago of buck rogers an old show
and uh
there was this guy of course i don't
know i know he was just
opening just a pop-up hour over here
open up
this metal thing and he just kind of
ripped it open he's at some alien he
goes on my plane i'm considered a
weakling among my people
yeah i'm poor yeah you're the loser yeah
you're doing pretty good in my book
yeah no kidding jets tickets i like that
i know guys got jet
jets tickets and hemorrhoid money still
pretty good gang real quick want to talk
to you about a new sponsor here on the
show
we love them you're going to love them
it's lucy nicotine oh yeah
lucy nicotine is a company founded by
caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative a couple of
brainiacs on the case
finally a tobacco alternative that
doesn't
stink all right they researched and
developed the product for over
three years okay and they're making it
for people
not for patients lucy has created
nicotine gum with four milligrams of
nicotine
that's one two three four millis oh yeah
and they have been fantastic flavors
they got wintergreen cinnamon they got
pomegranate which is the classiest
of all the fruit flavor yeah they got it
all baby they also if you don't if
you're not down with the gum they got a
four milligram lozenge and guess what
guess what flavor we're talking cherry
ice chadios
like everybody's favorite ice pops
cherry ice
uh they sent some to us it's fantastic
delicious as you guys know we're both on
uh we're both smoking cigs we're both
trying to kick it
and these help with the urge you pop a
piece of guy i've never been a big gum
guy
but this gum is a little bit different
so give it a [ __ ] shot
it's 20 21 time to put down the ciggies
and unplug the vape throw out the dip
is the real deal they have a
subscription to lucy that comes directly
to your door each month it's simple you
don't have to leave your house because
lucy
has the delivery down pat are you
garbage listeners listeners of the pod
go to lucy.co
and use promo code garbage to get 20 off
all products
for your first order including gum and
lozenges baby that's
lucy.co use promo code garbage at the
checkout to save
a couple of bucks what are we doing here
everybody needs a couple of bucks we're
going to lucy that's what we're doing
yeah also i have to give you the
disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical but
hey you know that by now
lucy.co and be sure to use the promo
code garbage
all right guys let's get into some
[ __ ] patreon questions so as you know
when you join the patreon we will answer
your garbage question
um with a guest it's a good [ __ ] time
we get so many submissions other you
know through instagram email whatever
this is just the best way to do it
um and we have a bit of a backlog but
we're [ __ ] getting them i know are
these general questions for everybody or
for me no these are for anybody yeah
uh so this is from billy batch shout out
to billy bats we try to
we tried it one time with list i was
like hey we're having lists back what
are your specific questions
and it's everybody knows a lot and they
just like brought up the saddest story
remember about his go card or whatever
oh
i thought he was gonna cry i was like
all right this is bad it's ignoring when
they do that because then they're like
who has a question and they ask you a
question about specifically something
you've already answered
yeah because they know it if they know
it yeah they're like say that again yeah
which is not really a question
sure yeah yeah tell me about your sad
go-kart uh here we like to get to the
real real
i don't know his story about the go-kart
but i'm happy that he was saddened by
that
good friend you are mr beer uh all right
this is from billy bats have you ever
had the fr
we're a big continental free continental
breakfast i love it i love the coffee
oh you gotta do it gotta have you ever
gone to a hotel that you weren't staying
at though
to get it that's a big road comic thing
if you're staying somewhere
like at the condo or somewhere that
doesn't have breakfast you find a place
that has breakfast walk in like you've
been there get a holiday in
your favorite room when you said it i
was like there's no way i'd have no
memory of doing that but i was like
there's no way i haven't done that yeah
you're a schemer that's what makes me
think i'm not sure if i've done that i
will tell you a great thing to do is you
go to like
in line at a really busy like uh in and
out or five guys or uh what's the one
where they put the egg on it
shake shack shake shack i don't know i
guess everybody puts the egg on yeah
anyways no
whatever it was but a really fast one
you know it's moving and you just
you just stand near the front of the
line for a while for like 10 minutes
and take somebody's burger no you don't
take somebody's burger and then
eventually they'll notice you're
standing there and they go hey where's
the cheeseburger with fries i've been
waiting for it and they go oh [ __ ] like
someone else must have taken it yeah so
they go
oh give me one second i'm sorry you
waited so long
what about your receipt or that little
buzzer
you know this might have been
pre-receipts like that but i feel you
could do that at like a
burger king or something but like
something where you're waiting that's
what i was thinking of fat burner
whipping them out whipping them out
hurry up and you're like hey i still
haven't gotten mine and my wife she's in
the car she took the receipt
yadda yadda i know what i'm doing this
weekend disgraceful
did take at uh uh la uh x the airport
all you guys steal from airports yeah
and they kept all the same cars
seat
and he's afraid the faa is going to come
after him for it like that
that's a federal crime god damn it
you're going to get me jacked up in
chicago i'll be in the pen
they have chain gang uh yeah just a
bunch of fat guys
i got two so far i got the air bus and i
got the boeing oh you got to get tons
you got
you are an airbus
so they kept calling this guy's name
smith john smith smith and just i was
sitting there waiting
i couldn't afford to eat not i'm like
dude it's been 15 minutes
there's no way he got on his flight he
had to like [ __ ] i gotta run took him
delicious lukewarm to quitos i don't
mind that especially when you're poor
you got to stick and move somehow
yeah and if you paid for whatever i
couldn't do it i don't have the
confidence to do it really
no well they're going to know you're
lying they're going to take one look at
you be like this fat guy he's just
circling
circling the burgers yeah we would have
recognized you there is that risk
because as you're getting it
somebody going hey hey what are you
doing that's my food there is that
slight risk
i think you'd be like oh [ __ ] my bad
that's you know it's whatever i don't
think there's a big follow-up question
you know
oh sorry i thought my wife something and
then you keep it moving
there's moments where you realize you're
holding a product in a store and you
realize
no one's been looking at you for a long
time and you're like oh i can get
it won't it's not a chance like i can
for sure get out of the store holding
this yeah but that's not you would know
what was the last time you stole
something
uh it has i just got back to america so
not this year
sure but every year once a month you
wouldn't do that [ __ ] in south america
would you
no you could caught stealing a heritage
[Laughter]
like struggling people yeah the airports
i get because everything's [ __ ]
jacked up to begin with so steal from an
airport i don't mind i don't do it
because i'm not a [ __ ] animal no you
don't like it
don't steal kids no no no no no no no no
no no
don't steal seriously it's not worth it
disagree with that
absolutely still it is worth it you've
got free stuff do you want to do it
do you want to be the guy getting caught
with the snickers oh
counterpoint do you want to be the guy
with the free snickers
[Laughter]
you i feel like i got the devil and
angel on my shoulder here
i used to bring up good cause well
they're not going to lock you up
i was in if it's at an airport they'll
take it it'll shake you down a little
bit
what do you think of what do you think
airports are like holy holy land
at the end of the day they don't work
they don't own that place they're like
[ __ ] who cares
always steal the neck pillows you just
walk around you
put it on your back then walk around
like shopping for stuff buy some gum
walk right out man how many neck pillows
do you need
so many i tried to throw them out i was
like
like a linebacker from the 70s oh man
great question all right next one coming
in this is just funny uh this is from
kevin do you pronounce the
l in salmon because if you do salmon no
i don't know
no oh good question you do hear some
people saying it and you're just like
you
check like did i hear right i think i'll
hear my mom drop it after a couple of
spritzers you know she'll be like i'll
take the salmon i'm like
jesus oh we're more of a flounder family
if you catch my trip
dude flanders trash do you know flounder
not really i've heard of it dude there's
jews aren't eating flounder
no way it's a real philadelphia south
jersey thing
that's what you went fishing for it's a
bottom it it's the eyes are on the same
side then we put it to you that way
it starts off like a regular fish and
then it just swims on the bottom
so much that it's other eye moves over
to the nose so both eyes are on the top
of it
wow yeah it's pretty good eating good
eating
[Laughter]
this is what you guys do every time on
your patreon just take their let's go
it's great yeah yeah they have they have
super funny [ __ ] they've learned we
were just talking about this as the show
has developed and they've heard
our questions a bunch they really come
up with like fantastic questions yeah
and they ask them they write them how we
would ask them you know what i mean
like there's there's never like pronouns
or it's like you have a do this or
whatever
this is another one this is from king
gay uh ever have those super weird
chapped lips as a kid
was that you i could see that being you
it was not no i probably had it already
right over there
i never used chapstick it was just like
there was never any point my lips were
perfect
that was such a tough look on a kid i
was always like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
it's like fire crews yeah what the [ __ ]
man why do only your lips look badly
burned
yeah you're seven what the [ __ ] going
on who did you rescue drink a glass of
water we had this kid
[ __ ] he would always it was a huge
crack right here
oh his bottom lip every [ __ ] winner
it's like dude
get some [ __ ] sealant or something
yeah call these guys that do the roads
we had a guy named baruch i can say his
last name but he would he just eat his
chapstick we'd see him in class
oh man probably hit with the ladies
i wonder what he's doing now he was a
[ __ ] nerd in fourth grade
i hope he's dead jesus he would eat his
chapstick what flavor was it regular i
don't think he discriminated i remember
there was a cherry there
yeah all right cherry i could i could
look the other way on that well
i could see licking them but like come
on if it's if you have some excess on
your lip and you
you know it gets in there if you take a
sip of water so i'm trying to fill up on
chapstick
i'd say i hear it's low in carbs
i can see that though i was a paste
eater when i was a kid
really yeah paste paste and dog food i
they couldn't keep me away from him
it was tough that explains your great
head of hair
he's got a great coat on him he really
does that's all that kibble
yeah i was all about it oh yeah she'd
keep it in the bin
and i'd go downstairs at our house and
mountaintop and [ __ ]
i'd be snacking down there oh come down
and get me on pace or on dog food
on dog food you didn't have pace at the
house that was a school thing right now
that would have been a problem yeah that
would have been a problem
and roll on deodorant for some reason i
always ate of hers
of my mother's i don't know why dude
what that's not
that's that's like no one's done that i
would lick it i would lick her deodorant
what the [ __ ] i'm telling you would lick
your mom's
we're gonna have to cut this you would
lick your mom's use deodorant
ew i never used the part i just was
thinking about this
i never thought about it like that you
know it's more like hell you can see
like at a child like oh this is what
you're going to become
like yeah he's eating everything around
the house it's so obvious like what
what'd you expect it to look like you
guys totally heard that wait till you
learn how to cook or got a car to go to
mcdonald's
he's eating food and then some yeah
you're eating objects so you're eating
household products
dog food omelette with a little bit of
secret oh man try it out just found out
h stands for herbert
sherbert um all right this is from will
bucks and we've talked we've touched on
this do you have a car
now or yeah yeah she's got a car last uh
over cause of covet i was like i gotta
go
what are you rolling in what can you
tell us what kind of way toyota
toyota new buy new or lease lease nice
it's all about the lease
i just you get a new car you don't put
that much into it you're gonna pay like
a grand or two more over the three years
than you would have
and then get out dude i i felt like i
got a [ __ ] key of fort
i don't even know what it is i got a key
i bought it via email i was like hey i'm
coming in
really yeah i'm like i don't want to
[ __ ] i never drove it nothing i'm
like just come in
i'll sign the papers give me the [ __ ]
keys he said done deal and i i literally
felt like a [ __ ]
millionaire like a new car brand new car
never had a brand new car that's amazing
he's got a little feeling he got a lease
yeah it's the best only three three
years don't go longer
anything happens to it when i take it
right in yeah my first new car i did
that at least i'm gonna pay for oil
changes or they do it no you gotta pay
for it they do the first year
what they do uh-huh he's a tough
negotiator i love how he has instantly
like you knew and you were so wrong but
you weren't like i think you have to you
were like no no no yeah this is the way
it is
i'm henry foley pleasure to meet you
let's get on with myself
do all the work there so they have
records of it right you don't have to do
it at that deal
like any toyota place yeah but they'll
have the records of like hey look i've
been doing this i've been doing that so
it keeps up it keeps the reach oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah you also can just not do
a
oil change and you still give it back
yeah they might bang out a little bit
though
they like to bang out if you don't get
another lease right yeah they want yeah
yeah they want to incentivize you get
another lease yeah
then once you get out of the lease by
the way these two guys are on my patreon
this same week
plug it in right yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
well yeah we'll put it in the notes and
uh we'll even we could do a bumper same
day
same day dual episodes today energy
basically so if you're listening
to the skeptic tank and listen to us
that's correct yeah well
aria's podcast is more of an svu type
thing
this is a little more mainstream this is
regular law and order shout out to
briscoe
you heard bill whatever waterston what's
his name
waters just died really yeah he was he
put a lot of a lot of criminals behind
bars shout out to sam
yeah he played by his own rules mccoy
we're talking about mccoy yeah
yeah that having a big funeral for him
from the [ __ ] some either the
mypd or the something is like because he
was a character on their thing they're
doing a big thing for him
i mean that's like rocky having a statue
that doesn't make any sense he played a
fictional he's probably a [ __ ] jerk
off in real life it's a big show i doubt
he was
not what are you not gonna what i don't
know sam waterson's not gonna die
i just remember it was sad when jerry
orbach died oh yeah shout out to
i mean come on dirty dancing he donated
his eyes to the science great abortion
giver
yeah that's what he was right no i think
he was a regular doctor that's why he's
upset he doesn't really generally like
doing abortions
but i'll do him or a miscarriage yeah
he's not ruining the [ __ ] summer you
know what i mean
i didn't go home after that
he already bought the tickets yeah
everyone's staying
um all right this is from will how long
is too long to keep a donut or the spare
tire on your car
oh interesting i thought he was gonna
say keep a doughnut in your fridge
which is another cookie all right yeah
all food questions
yeah i don't know sarah the answer is c
vegetables
everything goes to him they take care of
themselves that's a good thing about
veggies
you play defense for a couple of weeks
all sudden there's no more veggies yeah
right they rock i gotta get rid of this
donuts don't go bad though nope
yeah they don't they get harder but you
can still eat them oh yeah
sweetness is still there tasting [ __ ]
dog good point
they just stale donuts just turn into
eclairs
that's basically all it is ah the fact
that french pastry
yeah honestly i prefer a little bit of a
chew a little bit of a bite
i want to fight me back
i don't want some donuts you're just
going to lay down i want to i want to go
the distance with it
i say you got 24 hours though with a
doughnut in a car you it's like the
point is
either a mexican or a real place and you
get a real tire
or like the next day so tops if it
happened early in the morning and you're
like
i'm busy i can't get just go straight
and get a [ __ ] tire if you're busy
then it's like the next day
you might not have that kind of cash
that was always my problem i never had
the cash
new tires two bills that's why you go to
the mexicans i would do useful
bills 40 bucks
la they just they take [ __ ] off the at
the junkyard
yeah you're getting a used tire for like
50 years you want me to take a flight
from new york to los angeles get a tire
there's mexicans here whatever the
version of that is here
you can get there's places i've gotten
i've got my tire fixed at a guy just on
the corner like there was no
shop you just pull up and you double
park and he runs out with like a jack
and
so you're a nast bar you're a dominican
philly actually i've been through those
neighborhoods the in-between
neighborhoods of where the whites go
and then like you drive through and you
see people like it's like a partner
building a party building and then just
a
homemade sign says tires and stuff yeah
yeah just like written it's like a girl
they have like a garage or they built
like a hut yeah yeah you can do it for
sure
if you're going to the dealer for a tire
you're a [ __ ] jerk i don't go to the
dealer
i go to a tire place sounds like a
dealer
they don't sell cars there but i can't
just put any tire on my car i get
nervous that it's going to pop
i get some old so you would drive a
[ __ ] donut longer because you're
afraid a [ __ ] real tire is going to i
would like to have a quality tire on my
vehicle
he's got a big issue with his top he's
always the pressure's always going he's
always going i'm at a 32 i need a 34 i
think it's the extra cargo
i know i know exactly how much tire
pressure is in my car at all times
because i have a little a little
heads-up display that tells me burrito
wow yeah oh yeah gotta care about
something
yes god put w's on the board somehow big
man
it's that fall ball baby that and my
cardiovascular exercises
that matter to me uh all right growing
up i now
with you i don't know because uh the
religious upbringing
uh this was from chris rowe were you a
pop tart or toaster strudel family
no probably neither neither really was
there a kosher version actually i wonder
if
either of those were kosher but we just
weren't family
we were not a sweets family no sugar no
no twizzlers which were kosher we
couldn't have them you were like you
would you didn't prefer them or you
weren't allowed to have
we weren't a lot we wouldn't if they
were kosher we wouldn't have my mom
would never have bought them because you
have a lot of cheerios was as
deep as she went for sugar really honey
nut cheers are kosher here the only
pop-tarts that are kosher are the ones
that don't have frosting
oh wow oh who the [ __ ] wants a graham
cracker
what are we doing here yeah
[Laughter]
is that piranha cheese shout out to
bharat i'm a big veronica
shout out to burrata burrata if you're
there we'd love to go to the podcast
tag us call us um
what was the snack situation was it dude
honey nut cheers was as far as no snacks
because you have a sword you could go to
the butler's house the butlers would
have it the butlers would have
the butlers the families okay yeah the
neighbors and they would have they'd
always have twizzlers they'd always have
those [ __ ]
uh pretzel uh peanut pretzel they have
nibs that's two types of twizzlers
oh they're nibbles are great nibs are
great a lot of people don't know that
i'm not people don't even know what a
[ __ ] nib
is not a big fan i love them there's
actually
the smoothness is great i want a whole
smooth twizzler that seems generic to me
which they kind of have that with the
pool and pizza what a lot of people
don't realize is that
there's no actual or twizzlers product
that's the same the twizzlers that are
in the regular pack or a certain kind of
licorice
the ones that are in the little mini two
banger that you get at halloween they're
a little bit different and the nibs are
different
and then the pull-aparts forget about it
the pull-ups can i suggest something oh
yeah those are like the thin ones
can i suggest something that i know you
guys will be into so i get it the
environment we're we're all gonna die in
2040 whatever they're saying
use licorice's straws that's exactly it
oh i did that all growing up dude
i'm saying businesses do it instead of
those [ __ ] straws that evaporate
those things they suck you gotta [ __ ]
suck it down you got
three minutes before it's worth it yeah
if i'm out cut cut
boom and you could eat it at the end i
like doing strawberry daiquiri with a
with a sour
with a sour straw come on yeah you can
do different things that's good
i want nothing in return just have it
out yeah but your stroll expenses are
gonna go through the roof but you know
you guys that's how much stuff you raise
what do you mean it's a drink no you buy
red vines in bulk you can get them at a
pretty decent price
we're talking bare bottom prices i do it
anyway at the movies so what's the
difference
man there was nothing like there was
nothing like some fountain soda some
fountain coke through a [ __ ] twizzler
and you have it at the teeth were gone
by the end of the movie but still
you bypass compost completely there's
nothing there's no waste that's a
fantastic idea
thank you i like it i don't hate it who
owns a business do you have any
listeners or [ __ ] watchers that own
businesses
please no please oh yeah i think
probably so good yeah probably
we got a real employee heavy listing
yeah we're we're definitely
unemployed podcast with winners as
listeners probably jared freed maybe
jared freed not even scholes he has a
lot of them but there's not
they're not winners either i think just
maybe
you know who might listen to jared
freed's podcast is chloe
from chloe from uh by chloe i bet you
she'd be she'd be up for that idea
yeah if you got some kind of organic uh
licorice organic
twizzler yeah she might be in it bars we
people own bars
yeah we'll figure it out well i mean
yeah
we know bar owners who's chloe by chloe
the girl
in the village the the vegan thing on
the corner
if you walk out of the cellar to the
right so like bleeker and mcdougall it's
just those little like
gift gift bag things no no it was like a
whole
restaurant yeah like a restaurant like a
bakery restaurant sandwiches and stuff
i hate it really i hate it she was
packing them in a couple summers ago
yeah she was [ __ ]
killing it and then they closed it yeah
she opened up to the store next door to
it too
from chloe from chloe too chloe
bye chloe too chloe um all right next
one this is from rick this is a
two-parter
uh have you ever slept in your car part
two have you ever been woken up by a cop
for sleeping in your car
you've had to sleep in your car for sure
for a thousand percenters out to my car
like gigs or like catching a map yeah
catching out i i had to fly
back to la to like edit uh this is not
happening and then like i went straight
to an editing player that was just roy
woods right
[Laughter]
i love that guy
funny dude he was a great host
that was the most already joke ever
but yeah then i was like i gotta get a
hotel and everything was like taken or
expensive and i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then like i went to one and it was like
no i'm not staying here it's like a
motel type thing once just went to a
neighborhood and pulled my car back and
just like let's go
when i used to hook you from school okay
dude i haven't heard the term
hooky and so what are you in greece
you got a paper dude you can't be there
either i have playing hooky
these two were playing hooky yeah racing
at thunder road
the best is you sleep in a car and you
like you you kind of start it up to like
get a little heat going and then you
gotta cut it yeah yeah and then when you
gotta pee
it's like i'd either have to go
somewhere or just crack the door
lean over sure tap tap tap
male privilege yeah it's not bad uh
last night when you were last time you
were leaving here i was like midnight or
whatever
i was waiting for my uber my uber driver
got out he dropped someone off
right across the street and i was like
oh [ __ ] that's random i'm walk
so then he pulls up like i don't know 20
yards and i'm like oh whatever i'll just
walk to him i guess
and he gets out of the car walks over to
the passenger side opens the door and
just starts peeing as i'm like [ __ ]
five feet from him he used the passenger
side to block it but like dude piss
on the outside of your car piss away
you're pissing he's kissing
towards the car and i was like hey man
for kevin and he's like
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm like dude
take your time i get it how was the
piece you get a peek yeah
pretty good pretty reunited on them yeah
there you go got an uber driver say do
you mind if i go to the bathroom do you
mind if i pull over to the bathroom and
get gas
i've never had that i have and it's
always like why is the meter
yeah that's [ __ ] up yeah i've had cabs
do that i gotta
kind of pull over and get gas yeah but
like turn it off
yeah yeah hit pause or something or i'll
give you a flat rate yeah go in and grab
me something dude i had one guy in
philly literally go i got to stop here
and pick up my buddy
and we he picked up his buddy who was
like four blocks out of the way from
wherever and then his buddy was just in
the front seat with way
that was just in the back like dude what
in the [ __ ] is going on here
yeah i'd never get into a cabin there's
somebody else in the front seat that's a
[ __ ] toughness
yeah they're kidnapping me yeah you're
getting kidding me
i didn't i mean yeah whatever i didn't
care i didn't have a lot going on at the
time
it was somebody i was working at macy's
in center city for like eight bucks an
hour
um i've never been i've slept in the car
never been woken up you sleep in the car
we almost slept in the car the other day
together
we always took naps together yeah in his
jeep it's not i used to be able to do it
all the time like i drove for a while
and i would just
i would go i would get like a 20
breakfast at burger king put on stern
and i'd be out for like seven hours
for some reason i can't really do it now
i can't get comfortable inside
you got to be tired for sure yeah you
gotta it's gotta be like this is
the let like this is my only eye and
he's obviously not talking about you're
driving you're in the passenger seat and
you doze off oh no i
parked your car because there's a
movement there yeah it's like you're a
baby
yeah you're getting rocked there's
nothing better than when you were a
little kid and you were in the back seat
and like your dad or your uncle was
driving and the ac was on
back there yeah you get the sun and the
ac combo [ __ ]
out yeah when you park you kind of wake
up and they're like they carry
in oh i used to always pretend like i
was still asleep so they didn't carry me
i'm not getting up and walking
yeah like an [ __ ] yeah ruin my buzz i
could see you pretending like you're
asleep but you don't know how to pretend
you're like
[Laughter]
you're such a ham you're overactive
uh one time i fell asleep brian redband
rogan's old producer
gave me some weed that he was like it's
not that strong and it was like
stronger than normal um and fell asleep
at a red light
what on the way home put on the foot on
the get our foot on the brake i guess oh
[ __ ] i just like her honk i was like and
but like where am i kind of thing
you look you didn't hit the gas i am
lucky geez because me and ruben also got
lucky a lot a lot of drunk driving never
never
never turned up you were rumored we were
driving home one night in that same
situation there was a guy [ __ ] passed
out at a red light
so he had to like [ __ ] try to wake
him up he called the cops and stuff like
that
he was gonna kill himself or somebody
when he woke up he was gonna [ __ ]
dart right into traffic
yeah i'd love when you see a drunk
driver you're like just get out of his
way but like yeah you're to the right
it's the right thing you got you can't
dude you can't be driving me and rokin
saw a guy trying to
put his key into his back door for like
three or four minutes oh
out of the bar and then realize he was
just like that i mean we were like that
guy
are you [ __ ] kidding me he kept doing
it he was like and then he was like
and then he went to the front went right
through a red light
we're like uh let's hold back let's wait
a couple of minutes
20 burger king breakfast by the way well
i mean dude he already admitted to
eating paste and dog food what am i
going to call him out on actual food at
this point would you say you ate a 20
you ate 20. you would go spend 20
at burger king oh on breakfast breakfast
good cash to buy this was in like
this was in like the early 2000's too
yeah the most you could spend with
six yeah no come on don't paint me out
to be
the bad guy here supporting local
businesses
wait wait foley i have a question have
you ever yes toby have you ever at a
drive-through ordered two drinks
to make it look like your meal for you
was for two people
yes
i used to do that too i would be real
clever with the with the words that i
would use in my bigger days i would say
like i all i'd be like i need a bacon
egg and cheese
and also like every like it was for
someone i'm like oh yeah i also need
like i forgot about my wife
that's great i love fatties trying to
like try to reason with people so no no
you don't think i'm fat it's not because
i eat too much
it's just i would say and she's gonna
have
all right or no she doesn't want to
drink um
the biggest move is when i when i feel
like i order too much delivery
if nobody else is home act like you yell
into the bedroom yeah yeah
it's here babe cheers thanks man bye
yeah i mean on the patreon one time we
went over our last seamless orders
the three of us and it was like yours
was like devastating
it was like a half a cheesecake for
breakfast two sandwiches
it was a lot for breakfast another half
for lunch and then
seven more sounds like
it sounds like a meal prep plan if i
ever heard one let's keep a fresh
cheesecake around now oh man
you should do a [ __ ] a weight loss uh
commercial
but just look like you and then just be
like do you want to
look your best and just like just tell
them you're real
what you're eating chinese for breakfast
the pounds will fly
i used to be 900 pounds i don't know
uh all right this one's from bryce while
we're on the cars and we've touched on
this
way early on in the show uh have you
ever uh
used the windshield washing squeegee to
clean more than your car
a thousand percent yeah that's yeah it's
a trash
it's a poor move the way you guys
[ __ ] try to explain away your dollar
pizza habits
as oh i was poor instead of saying it
was disgusting but i had no choice
you're like no it's cool
there is an emotional connection i i had
it over the weekend
i think you're being too hoity-toity i'm
surprised too
a dollar slice some dollar slices are
okay some the best they can do is okay
fresh hey i'm okay with it
number one pizza city in the world you
guys are yeah but i i think i think
percy's going to be
one of the best in new york i'll go down
there and i'll take a slice and i'll put
it on the ground and i'll step on it
and it's now two dollars i got to talk
to percy yeah they've they
they had to increase it there you go so
now you can have it that's not a dollar
slice anymore there's a lot
of that was nice if it's two dollars
it's double what a dollar slices
you're talking about a different thing
this guy's bonkers
all right take it easy i just raised the
prices what was the question
hey whatever you say big guy but there's
a lot there's more bad pizza in new york
this is the number one bad pizza city
there's better it's like it's like
comics like yeah there's a lot of great
comics
you know and there's also a lot of
shitty comics me and kurt metzger used
to like [ __ ] on each other which is the
worst comedy in new york or l.a
back when we were both reversed and uh
and he would like throw out some shitty
l.a comic then i'd throw out some shitty
new york college
we're like i don't risk none of us
respect that he's not we're not
he's not on our team yeah wait what was
the question uh using this oh yeah yeah
i would always car wash full car wash
yeah what the whole car
whole car i mean i got thrown out a
couple times and you won't need a dollar
slice
come on this guy's everywhere yeah this
guy's all over i can't get a read on
this guy
i do it to clean off the gas if a little
gas spills that's the gentleman
move i i don't even put that [ __ ] on my
windows
after this was like maybe this was right
before i got my new car and i
shout out you know rest in peace to the
montego uh it was i parked under a tree
for like two weeks
and it was just [ __ ] bird [ __ ] pollen
like [ __ ] branches
twigs dude and i like i was at the gas
station for 15 minutes scrubbing my
[ __ ] car
i was really hoping a listener didn't
see me like wow
what about the poor slob that has to use
it after you i mean the water's dirt
what do you
i mean i don't care about your next [ __ ]
all over their window
well they're cleaning birds [ __ ] off
their window it's not like they're
pulling up with a brand new car
yeah they're not changing their baby's
diaper with it yeah it's like what the
[ __ ] it's going on the outside of their
car
yeah it's like oh same boat i was in
before i guess
that's the worst case scenario yeah i'm
really just smearing bird [ __ ] on my car
that's a tough look yeah it's not great
there's a lot that as you guys get
fans it's like there's a lot like it
sucks but you can't
do certain things anymore in case
someone sees you it's not just some
schlub doing it
it's like oh i know those guys yeah it's
funny doing it you mention that i
believe
i got caught picking my nose checking my
nose is the one yeah driving down second
avenue
unless it was just some random person
but this woman was hanging out of the
back of a jeep and i was driving had the
windows down you know what i mean the
radio's on
um and they pulled up next to me and i
could have swore she was yelling foley
but she had her phone out and she was
like while i was driving and i'm pretty
sure i had just done a
[ __ ] got a flick
nice that's my private time in the car
it's right clean house
don't touch nothing in there eating 20
breakfast
um all right we got a couple from
facebook as well have you ever had a
throw this is from eric
uh have you ever had to throw a pan away
because you cooked something and never
cleaned it this seems right up your
[ __ ] alley yeah yeah for sure i have
yeah yeah recently no
no no it's been a while but i was in la
i would leave stuff in there for so long
at that second
i would you ever get to the point where
your sick is full of dirty dishes and
like you need a dish to eat something
so you wash one use it right back in the
dirt yeah
i can't do it yeah at some point it's
just so kicked in there that you're like
yeah the bottom of that extra like in
colle every every time i moved out of
college i just
trashed all i would just put the stuff
that was in the
because it was just in the sink forever
i put it into a [ __ ] beer like a 20
like a case of beer like an empty case
of beer and was just [ __ ] right out
the window
yeah you know what's a classic move is
being like we it's we have dishes
because we have too many dishes
so you throw out everything but like
four of everything and then it's just
four things in the digital yeah then
it's just four dirty things
that's really all you need especially if
it's just you or you and and your
significant other yeah that really is
all you need and the rest
it really is just like so it will force
us to wash it over two meals yeah
i got a dishwasher now so i'm [ __ ]
the living room
fancy i have had one before i didn't
have my last place but they're like god
it makes it so much easier having one in
new york is [ __ ]
just the mini one is all you need yeah i
have one that's right yeah it's like
like the size of a trash compactor
that's clean living yeah it's not too
shabby
um all right this one's from jordan ever
get a payday loan which i can not for
use
for see you getting a payday loan i
don't know what that is uh
payday loan is you would take if you
needed money that would give you money
like
you know say it's monday you apply for a
payday loan you can get it by tuesday
but then you have another business from
like a from a loan
but not from your job not from your job
not like hey can i get it you get it
till your payday like so you're kind of
signing over your check to them at like
an insane
an insane range sometimes it's like 72
percent like it's like a banana wow no
you don't pay by friday they really [ __ ]
i've never got one of those but that is
a new business that i will be going into
the [ __ ] are never gonna learn how to
[ __ ] be smart welcome to hari's
payday
loans ahri's loans never pay off yeah
that's right
best interest rates in town he'll be
among the worst but
there was one on uh like it was like ran
by like like on an indian reservation
because they have like they can play by
their own rules a little bit
and it was like you know soaring eagle
payday loans or whatever
and at the bottom in like the super fine
print it was like 80 gotcha
it was like 88 rate or something like
that wow if not paid back in the first
couple of days
because they know you're not going to
pay it back if you need money to get to
friday
when friday comes you're not going to be
in a better financial situation
correct nothing else is coming in
exactly yeah yeah
i was never really privy to that i have
gone to my boss and said hey can i get
my
money now yeah a little bit up front and
also i've tried the j i've tried the uh
j is it jg wentworth the lender my money
and i have a lending tree
oh that's what they still hit me j.g
wentworth was different that was if you
which is also bad money if you like had
a slip and fall and they were like oh
we'll give you 10 000
a year for the next 10 years so that
that's worth a hundred thousand dollars
in 10 you know after the total of 10
years jg wentworth would go
we'll give you 60 now and then sign over
to all the payments
debt collectors do so if you owe
somebody 100 bucks and eventually like
we're putting you in the collections
they buy it for someone else and he's on
that debt for like give me i'll
take that 100 for 70. yeah and i i have
a 70
chance greater or less than getting that
from him and they're like hey man we're
going to ruin your credit
so they probably might get 100 but also
you're deadbeat
so they might not and then eventually
they sell that they sell it all off to
sell it all so at some point if you've
been in collections long enough
you say hey will you take 25 yeah and
they're like yeah we bought this debt
for
three yeah so it's all win for us dude i
i mean i don't know
i'm very well versed in this uh this
world
uh yeah my credit will uh will
will reflect that but i owed macy's 800
bucks
for i'm talking how do you seven years
work there dude how do you owe them
money
i told you because in order to get the
employee discount you had to put it on a
credit card you had to put it on a
macy's charge card like credit card you
must have been fly that year
yeah i was just buying dude instead of
doing like instead of like washing
clothes i would just buy underwear and
socks and [ __ ] on the [ __ ] i didn't
know how
i was [ __ ] why don't you steal that
macy's what yeah i don't steal man i
don't steal i come i have some sort of
no no
i i didn't ask you if you stole i said
why didn't you steal yeah i don't know i
just
i still don't steal i never really stole
i still don't
we're on a clean shop here because i'm
an honest man um wait i have a question
for you yeah if someone venmo's you
do you pay the money for the instant
transfer or you just hit the
keep it all wait the two to three days
for it to transfer
yeah i don't even know what that is all
right so you can so someone sends you a
hundred bucks
and you have a hundred bucks in your
venmo balance you can transfer it
immediately
to your debit card but they charge you
like they wet their beasts they they
charge you a couple of points oh yeah
i've never done that so i
just have a balance i'm i'm not hand of
mouth so i don't have to like i need
that
i'm not hand to mouth either but i for
sure get it out of venmo's
[ __ ] grimy balls right into my bank
account really yeah
i'd be interested to know what you had
in your venmo fifty eight thousand
dollars just
sit down are you joking no no you're
like i just looked yesterday i've had to
transfer marissa's money at 58 000.
i don't know i don't have anything in
there i probably like a couple hundreds
that's it
just like moving around you have an amex
card yeah
you do yeah for a limited damn look at
this guy
we don't do limits you have to have a
limit you don't have a black card
no it's not about dude we are choosing
are like a different thing it's not the
limits is like there's no there's no
specific jewish american express
card there is and there's a jewish tsa
line does we have a
[ __ ] you guys don't even know about i'm
converting
it's just a deli
you got to walk through cat in the back
of cats yeah besides i
yeah pretty young thing or pretty hot
yeah you pick up the phone and someone's
like hello you're like can i come in and
then the back of that wall
yeah i tried it and dude the number was
not working when like they were like hey
hit pound six nine or whatever
and i was like trying to show my buddy
i'm like yeah this place is pretty cool
and i could not get it
i was like yeah this place [ __ ] sucks
dude wait hang on you have to have a
credit card limit
uh yeah i yeah yeah i'm sure i do yeah
but he's saying but he's
he also operates in a world where you
need your limit higher me too i just
applied for it yeah yeah yeah yeah i
gotta get more that's our limits guess
our limits what do you think we're
working i'm paying like a green grocer
every [ __ ] month and they still won't
[ __ ] buy five thousand seven thousand
five thousand five hundred and two
hundred dollars you think i'd be
here if i had five grand in credit
legitimately every once in a while just
get an email or a text from my credit
card
saying your limit's been raised i gotta
pay i gotta
buy for it i got an email from them
saying hey we got our eye on here yeah
well i gotta
say well yeah what's going on i never
carry a balance i just like it just pays
i do it at the end of the month too but
they still won't [ __ ] bump me up
and my credits at 7 20. i don't know
what's going on here's a fun one because
now you guys are headlining on
uh on you're together yeah going out
there what's the united states
uh june 18th it'll be in atlantic city
it's probably sold out
maybe there might be a couple of tickets
left second show when chicago sold the
[ __ ] out
great we got indiana coming up uh
indiana yeah indy coming up in uh
june june 23rd okay every once in a
while a club owner will hit you with
this like hey do you want some of that
in cash
now sometimes this just happened to me
and i didn't know what to do i panicked
i thought
hold on for a second i thought you just
did that to shift the conversation
away from finances i was talking about
finances
yeah it's part i was going to be
impressed that was a good deflection but
he's also a good plugger too
[Laughter]
yeah he's good man's a broadcaster you
should forget about my net worth don't
you guys have some dates coming up
that's what i thought you did i was like
oh this guy's good but they'll hit you
up so sometimes you go they're like oh
[ __ ] i don't have an atm i need to tip
the bartender like hey can i get 100
right now and then just take it out of
my thing um but they'll hit you with do
you want some of that in cash
which is like i was always like no just
the whole check i'll deposit the whole
check
and then it hit me like oh you're not
going to report the party you think
that's the case
it is the case so when they say that go
well how much can you give me in cash if
it's all of it
if you feel comfortable getting home
with all of it do it all and they'll
they'll write down a small
ours is really only like 300 bucks
anyways they got that one i'm not
reporting it
some of that in cocaine please yeah for
sure what do you tip the
staff like if the green room staff well
you know so if they tip if they waited
on me the whole weekend yeah
five dollars and then
[Laughter]
and a signed head shot yeah i give my
album
i'll go like a hundred usually that's
something yeah that's just because i was
a waiter
like a hundred then i worked at club the
weekend he is he is good with that kind
of stuff i mean he
[ __ ] he you let you wet everybody's
beak around you he went our beak from
the other day which i was [ __ ] blown
away by and thank you very much i was
very honest and paid him oh by the way i
was leaving he left me the money
he goes i would have found that
eventually no you wouldn't i would have
hunted you down like he would
never have broken it
he's not running anywhere oh i go yeah
and then the bartenders if you're going
to be there all week and you want them
excited you're going to come back and
also like you do nightly or at the end
because sometimes
yeah so nightly i'll go like 20 or 40
especially if like
i'm bringing the head the mc and the
whatever then i'm like i'll i'll
take care of it i'll be like 40 a night
nightly cost me more
yeah yeah at the end of the week um
yeah it's just like those are the
employees of the club you got to pay
them yeah and then you go cheap on other
people
yeah he's good with that kind of stuff
man he's a good guy rock solid
good bat mitzvah gifts i got to tell you
i mean camping's a little weak
camping's
if you could only do cash yeah what
would you be giving her
this weekend uh geez i don't know um
i i i i have no idea
500. that's pretty that's right it's not
bad
that might be too high actually it's a
[ __ ] 12 year old i don't know what do
they need money i don't know
but bob mitchell you guys make like
[ __ ] 50. i would go big man
i know but i remember getting a grand
from like my richest richest aunt
uh and it was like jesus christ do you
remember what you made total for your
bar mitzvah i think like
15 grand 15 grand
he's never going to get over that 15
great you handed me
15 grand at 12. yeah
dog food is farsi i can see
kibble's for everybody my friend let me
get a ride to petco will you
a couple of milk bones bring the
deodorant oh my gosh
15 grams 15 grand i got 200 bucks and
never
[ __ ] saw it you didn't deserve that
fair enough for what communion communion
yeah yeah what's the difference between
communion and environment this is when
you take on the religion bar mitzvah's
gonna become a man you becoming it you
become an adult
i was a man back then i was making moves
i bet you would [ __ ] the lobby
it was a good looking kid herbert foley
don't tell her
that's right that's your new name by the
way that guy was a christian shout out
to herbie
herbe i like it uh kirby and t-bone
all right let's do a couple of more and
then we gotta [ __ ] wrap up here this
has been a [ __ ]
heater um this is also from facebook
this is from cheyenne d
this is nuts to me do you use a new
towel every time you shower
what that's crazy that's nuts that's not
that's not a trash thing i don't even do
that at a hotel what are you talking no
obviously not don't let him in
tell them no that's not nuts the
question should have been phrased the
other way
how long do you yeah have you ever gone
you know weeks
yeah yeah yes yes if i'm at my mom's
house i'd [ __ ]
fresh one every time really i'll use
i'll use two one for my face one for my
body
he kid me keep her working she does them
fresh too i don't know what she puts in
there
but at home forget it my girlfriend goes
like one or two like one or two showers
what i don't i have one shower i have
noticed sometimes a week a towel will
actually have a musk or something oh
yeah it's a moldy wet and then it's like
then you gotta go yeah but i feel like
for me it's like i always forget
to throw that in like you know i always
get to watch and then i just
grab it again and then i'm gonna go
separate then i'm in the shower i'm like
oh [ __ ] i meant to do this yeah and then
you're gonna use it right there
yeah because you're [ __ ] jammed up
because oh like okay so
regular people with regular lives don't
understand this what comics do it's like
we don't really have a second towel or a
towel like a
cabinet where you're like uh i'll just
go get a new one yeah yeah
i have what my wife has like four i have
that now but up until i moved
with my girlfriend yeah have you ever
dried off with not a towel oh yeah i was
a big t-shirt guy for a long time oh for
sure
t-shirts yeah dirty t-shirts paper towel
paper paper towel
my college roommate used to do that my
boy flip it's insane
[ __ ] wow a handful of paper towels to
dry himself
air dry is a good one in really hot
weather places i use a hair dryer
hair dryer i use wow i have to do it
because i have to make sure that i
uh try the glutes just a little inside
baseball
um but i have to make sure that i get
everything dry
down in this situation so later on it
doesn't start swamping up on me
wow i got to make sure everything's bone
dry and a little powder
take care of what you care about and
that's his take actually before we move
on can i do a quick
suggestion please guys uh [ __ ] trash
nation
whatever you guys are i don't know where
you call your fans that's pretty good
actually
we don't have a name for them listen i
used to have the most downloads of any
[ __ ] episode and i've been eclipsed
so i'm gonna [ __ ] cheat the system i
want you to go to that [ __ ] other
episodes i had and click the [ __ ] out of
it and get me above that goddamn guineas
the stefano
[ __ ] trash soda get me above them
again do whatever you can
[ __ ] click click refresh refresh
refresh get me above them i need to be
back at first yeah he's nuts he i caught
him commenting on
a video the other day we uploaded he
goes arisha fears was better
commented by re [ __ ] shafir if you
haven't seen
if you haven't seen ari's episode it's
absolutely fantastic we filmed it at gas
it looks beautiful it's absolutely fun
and fantastic gotta check it out
yeah yeah it looks okay
no t-bone producing it's like what do
you mean i set up this whole group
exactly uh all right this was in this is
def
definitely in both of your times wheel
houses uh
did you ever this is from mike on the
patreon did you ever order the 12 cds
for a penny
from like cd baby or cd now if you want
to talk about theft
yeah let's do this then you got me you
got me dead to run
because you wouldn't even pay the penny
i wouldn't dude i
they [ __ ] at first still don't
understand it at 13 i was like
these guys are [ __ ] suckers
i signed up my mom my dad i that was
listen here's the thing
that was when cds became big and they
were reissuing
everything on cd billy joel's greatest
hits
hot rocks all the [ __ ] great classic
rocks all that stuff was
all coming back out and jams for sure
[ __ ] clean the house you have to
there was it was either 12 for a penny
or 10 for the price of one with nothing
more to pay ever
12 for the penny you still owe them a
bunch but how are they gonna come get
you
it didn't make any sense i still don't
get i'm pretty good business-minded
person i went to college
and i still don't understand they get
your address they re-run them so it's
like you don't they're not paying full
price to the artists and stuff they're
just like
whatever but like they don't
once they have your address mark they're
like we're not shipping that anymore
after you they get a few
oh a few what was the point that was
like 40 cds well they're hoping you were
paid
they went out of business right i think
so i would assume so i worked at the
university
of cd now i was uh with that i don't
know it was i forget what it's called
it's called columbia house
bmg those are the two yes so i worked at
we logged in packages university of
maryland we give out uh phone numbers
north hill service desk we give out
phone numbers if people lock their keys
out they come show id
and we log packages too big for the
little box so like you call them up like
hey you got a package waiting for you
so it hit us we're the ones logging the
packages in
so we just started ordering music one
hit [ __ ] get their album get their
whole catalogue it doesn't matter
anything you get just [ __ ] get it get
it get it get it get it the early days
of internet twos you could like
shop for everything one of the early
ones you just have to stick out lick a
[ __ ] stamp and put it on there yeah
12.
anything we ordered two rooms that don't
exist the bathroom had a room number the
[ __ ]
janitor closet had a room number we just
make up names anne arundel
uh mrs fields whatever and then you get
a package to a room that doesn't exist
and
all our friends would be like hey you
know like who's mrs fields i'm like oh
that was mine and then just
rack up see that's my kind of crap i can
get behind that
i don't go for the nickel and dime [ __ ]
that's white collar [ __ ] yeah
all the time they found out they called
the [ __ ] r.a was in charge of us
and they called one by one all of us
into our office were in trouble and they
just said columbia house
yeah they called their boss like
sometimes there's been nine thousand
orders tonight
it was for like seven months straight
every couple days we'd have a new box
and so like what is their 19 000
apartment building
apartments exactly and so they were like
we know who else did it we need you to
tell us to come clean about everything
and i was like no i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna report
come clean yeah college get the [ __ ] out
of here
yeah deny deny deny they said you can't
keep your job we already know you did it
you can't keep your job unless you tell
us who else did it and i was like
[ __ ] no but i was like no i can't i
can't and they go okay you're fired
and then they fired me and then
everybody else ratted on everybody else
went down with the ship i like it good
man good man mr fear
yeah this guy's [ __ ] solid he's rock
solid he's trashy but sure
sure rock solid guy yeah he's rock solid
all right let's wrap it up that was a
[ __ ] heater baby fantastic episode
ari
thank you so much there's anything you
want the folks out there to know that
you have coming up et cetera
yeah i got a uh youtube channel now
shafir youtube.com check out these guys
this week it's today
same day this shops go over right now
on youtube.com the ru garbage we've
discussed what
actually makes someone garbage um it was
a fun app had a couple of pops we shot
it here tooties we shot in a couple of
pops yeah i just got back it's my first
shot one from back here in america here
we go i love it we love it so it's great
i got a patreon also patreon ari shafir
and uh
yeah thanks for having me guys thank you
guys got a great podcast i love the
[ __ ]
trash nation and the [ __ ] he's really
pushing he's gonna send us a [ __ ]
cease and desist order from one of his
[ __ ] cousins
he's gonna be like listen trash nation
is uh taking off it's pretty popular
pretty
clear i said it it was on video proof
we'd like to take you camping white
water and discuss this uh proposition
uh what do you got 500 limit that's nuts
i got
two i got 200 and i tried to i tried to
get it what can you buy
i can't i can't put my cell phone bill
on it it's [ __ ] insane
uh guys please make sure you view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube
uh and then patreon.com also the live
shows the link will be
in here let's go i think we i think we
just got a text right on the second show
in atlantic city so [ __ ] get tickets
for that uh chicago sold out indy's
coming up we got to move tickets there
we also have cleveland
boston uh rhode island [ __ ] all over
providence so [ __ ] get some [ __ ]
tickets we have one of the live shows
they're we just posted a clip they're
[ __ ] we closed them out together for
like 20 minutes
it's so [ __ ] fun that's awesome it's
like just [ __ ] on the crap because
people want to be [ __ ] on
and people ask questions ahead of time
yeah we have each
show has its own email so they email
them in and then we kind of
field them ahead of time you know and do
you say hey so-and-so
yes where's where's frank at and then
frank oh you're here with uh [ __ ] on
frank a little bit
to be honest [ __ ] frank frank what the
[ __ ] are you doing get your [ __ ]
together
i love you frank and then he gets to
ask his questions so then i say is this
yeah and then like i mean sometimes i'll
read it or they can yell it like
whatever it's just like a com it's it's
a conversation starter
it's a great time so much it's fun stuff
gang we love you so much we'll see you
next week
peace